the movie opens up with the introduction
of The Banana Splits a popular
children's television series featuring
four animatronic animal characters
fleegle the Beagle Bingo the orangutan
drooper The Lion and snorky the Elephant
the show's human co-star Stevie is also
an essential part of the show elsewhere
a young boy named Harley who is a big
fan of The Banana Splits dresses up in a
snorky costume and creeps into the
living room there he startles his
sleeping mother Beth she jumps up with a
scream thinking there's a wild animal in
the house but it's only her son Beth
scolds Harley for being up so late but
the latter is too excited as it's his
birthday nonetheless she tells him to
wait for a few hours and Tucks him into
bed following this Beth goes straight to
her Elder son Austin's room and
confronts him for returning home late
she is worried that he might end up with
the bad guys however Austin mentions
that he is already 19 so she shouldn't
worry about him he also requests her to
not tell anything to his stepfather
Mitch Beth agrees but only on the
condition that he be more careful from
now on the following morning as everyone
is busy with the birthday preparations
Austin sneaks inside Mitch's room and
attempts to steal some money but to his
bad luck Mitch catches him in the ACT
making up for a very awkward encounter
later the whole family gathers to
celebrate Harley's birthday and showers
him with gifts Austin brings out a magic
wand that expands with the push of a
button while Beth and Mitch provide him
with tickets to the live show of The
Banana Splits Harley is ecstatic with
these gifts and soon the entire family
leaves for the studio along the way they
also pick up one of Harley's classmates
Zoe from her house in the next scene the
family arrives at Taft Studios where
they meet the show's Hostess Paige as
well as other excited audience member
first page announces a no cell phone
policy but a mischievous couple Thad and
Poppy sneaks one in anyway snorky's
gonna have their balls for that after a
while when The Banana Splits finally
show up in their small car Harley gets
so excited that he runs to them
fortunately snorky stops the car just in
time preventing an accident while the
atmosphere outside is absolutely crazy
things are the opposite inside the
show's manager Andy goes straight to his
producer Rebecca and orders her to
cancel all upcoming shows he reveals
that The Banana Splits have become a
flop and this will be their last taping
ever moments later Paige appears on
stage and addresses everyone to make the
program more interesting she asks the
audience to check if their tickets have
a star on the back the lucky ones who
have it will get the chance to meet the
members of The Banana Splits backstage
the mischievous couple Thad and Poppy
are among the lucky ones but Harley is
devastated that his family couldn't get
a single star soon the show begins and
the characters of The Banana Splits get
on stage and start performing their
human leader Steve does not show up on
time so Paige goes to check on him in
the changing room she finds him
completely wasted and not willing to
join the team you think this is bad you
should see what blippi did says Steve
right then Austin who told his parents
that he was going to the bathroom
arrives there and tells Paige that he
wants to talk to her once they head to a
separate room he explains that his
brother is a huge fan of the banana
split and that it is also his birthday
so it would be a dream come true if he
were given a chance to meet the banana
Splat after hearing him out Paige
promises to do the best she can
elsewhere Stevie overhears Andy talking
over the phone with someone he mentions
that The Banana Splits program has been
canceled because it doesn't fit his
vision as soon as Andy puts down the
phone Bingo arrives there and kidnaps it
turns out the orangutan character also
overheard the conversation next Stevie
arrives on the set and informs the other
members of the Banana Split team that
it's their last show soon the final
taping of the show ends and the audience
is asked to leave only the ones with
stars on their tickets can head
backstage but to everyone's surprise
Paige also calls up Harley and his
entire family making them excited on the
other hand Stevie insults The Banana
Splits members and expresses his
happiness about the cancellation of
their show he even spits in the face of
drooper to vent out his frustration
unfortunately this turns out to be a bad
idea as drooper gets enraged and ends up
inserting a giant lollipop deep into
Steve to Steve's throat killing him
brutally afterward the lucky audience
members are taken backstage where they
get to meet The Banana Splits and begin
taking pictures together Beth asks
Austin to look after the kids while she
goes to find Mitch at the same time a
middle-aged man Jonathan talks to Paige
and requests that he let his daughter
Parker meet the producer of the show he
mentions that his daughter is very
interested in place and wants to give an
audition to prove her Talent when Paige
refuses he decides to secretly take
Parker to the producer himself he
eventually finds Rebecca and requests
her to observe his daughter's
performance however the producer bluntly
refuses saying that the Banana Splits
show has been canceled this upsets
Jonathan but he is not ready to give up
he now wants to talk to the manager of
the show Andy himself outside the studio
Beth finds Mitch but shockingly learns
that he has been cheating on her all
this time she angrily confronts him
about it but Mitch doesn't seem to care
he asserts that he was compelled to see
other women because she always spends
more time with her sons Austin also
arrives there and tries standing up for
his mom but Mitch completely ignores him
and walks away let's all cross our
fingers and hope that Mitch will bump
into drooper moving on Thad and Poppy
make their way to fleegle's magic shop
and start live recording the place Thad
even gets down to his knees and
romantically proposes to Poppy which she
accepts unfortunately their happy moment
doesn't last long as fleegle shows up
out of nowhere and attacks that he
brutally finishes off the man by
dissecting him in half poppy who
witnesses everything screams in horror
but there is no one to help her after a
while she is also about to be eliminated
when suddenly fleegle hears someone
approaching he rushes to check outside
only to find the two kids unaware of
what's Happening Harley requests that he
be taken to his favorite character
snorky and in response fleegle nods in a
green meant meanwhile Jonathan and
Parker arrive at Andy's office but he's
not around instead they find drooper who
immediately Burns Jonathan's face Parker
screams hysterically and tries to run
away but ends up being kidnapped by
Bingo outside Mitch is minding his own
business when he hears a hurling sound
approaching him when he turns around he
sees snorky in his car driving toward
him at full speed terrified Mitch runs
to save his life and snorky follows
closely in the next scene Beth and
Austin return to the set where they left
the kids but failed to find them around
this makes Beth very anxious and she
starts scolding her other son their
conversation is interrupted when
Jonathan suddenly arrives with a burnt
face and informs them that the Banana
Splits have gone Bonkers as soon as
Rebecca hears this she asks Paige to
call 9-1-1 the latter frantically rushes
to the room where the phones have been
kept but learns that all of them have
been destroyed to make matters worse the
landlines have also been disconnected
because of this Beth and Austin start
searching for the kids on their own
until they are attacked by Bingo they
engage in a deadly tussle and Against
All Odds the heroic mom manages to push
Bingo down from a height hence saving
her son Bingo down after this they find
poppy in a devastating State she is
grabbing thad's hand assuming that he is
still alive Beth sympathizes with her
loss and inquires if she is seen Harley
and Zoe with a soft tone poppy reveals
that fleegle captured the kids earlier
but she doesn't know where they are
being kept elsewhere we learn that
Harley Zoe and Parker have been locked
in the workshop as they are struggling
to get out Carl the inventor of The
Banana Splits appears in front of them
he appears to be compassionate and
immediately lets them out however the
kids take Revenge by tricking him inside
the cell and locking him meanwhile The
Banana Splits sees Rebecca and Jonathan
and transport them to one of the stages
this sloppy time course where they are
made to dance for their lives but in the
end fleegle uses a key to stab Jonathan
in the back while druper destroys
Rebecca with a hammer what the on the
other hand the kids come upon snorky
while looking for a way out despite the
dire circumstances Harley is excited to
finally meet his favorite character he
tells his friends that snarky is a good
person and hearing this the latter also
agrees to help them elsewhere as the
adults are searching for the kids they
arrive at the workshop and notice Carl
Paige immediately inquires how they can
stop The Banana Splits but with a sad
face Carl mentions that they can't The
Banana Splits are programmed to keep
performing and since the Show is
canceled they have become violent as the
group is discussing they hear some music
coming from the other room and to decide
to follow it however poppy stays behind
and grabs a creepy mask that was
apparently designed for the fifth Banana
Split member Hootie as soon as she puts
it on she becomes controlled by the
programming and becomes violent Carl
begs to be released from the cell but he
too meets a tragic demise elsewhere the
adults reach another room and get horror
to learn that flegel and drooper have
been amusing kids with cruel and
disgusting acts like cutting Andy's
limbs off and burning Stevie's dead body
what am I reading at the same place
snorky brings Harley Zoe and Parker and
Chains Them Up with the other children
surprisingly snorky also hands Harley
the keys to the chains after he leaves
Harley quickly unlocks the chains and
releases the children seeing this Beth
orders Austin and Paige to guide the
kids to safety while she starts fighting
with fleegle and drooper at one point
she nearly gets killed but her sons
arrive in the nick of time and rescue
her then the family heroically fights
against fleegle and droop and eventually
kills them after this they rush to the
exit door but Bingo the orangutan
suddenly shows up and traps them it
appears as if the good guys are about to
meet their Doom as the giant monster is
poised to attack them however at the
last second snorky arrives there and
starts tussling with his friend the
fight is a deadly one in which Bo both
The Banana Splits characters get injured
badly but it is Harley's favorite snarky
who prevails in the end unfortunately he
too passes away due to his injuries in
the last scene the group finally gets
out of the studio and at the same time
the police also arrive everyone is tired
and scared from the encounter but Austin
still doesn't miss his chance to flirt
with Paige to his Delight she
reciprocates his feelings with a kiss
after a while an injured Mitch
approaches Beth and mentions that is
finally realized her importance in his
life however Beth punches him in the
face saying she wants a divorce
after the group finally departs a now
crazy poppy starts driving in The Banana
Splits buggy she is poised to exact
revenge on her Fallen Brothers the movie
ends as fleegle also comes to life and
starts laughing maniacally you're
welcome in advance for the nightmares
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching